Hey, last guest. I've
come to set up my house. Miya-sama.
[Music]
I've
never been very good at using a skewer, so isn't it
painful? Why, why are
you so devoted to me
?  [Music]
and the others stopped coming in less than a month,
but you've been
coming back and forth over the past three years, and
I haven't treated you
as well as I have.  Have you
ever been hit or kicked
? Do you know that Kami-sama's kicks don't hurt at all? That's
right. It
's nothing compared to when my siblings fought. I was able to take
care of Miya-sama in this way.  I
just couldn't leave you alone, so there's no particular
reason. It's almost time. Come on,
Oimiya-
sama, please raise your head like that.
I can't repay your loyalty right now.
Thank you.  Please forgive me for all I can do.
[Music]
God's basket is in Temiya-sama. I'm
praying for you.
[Music]
I